- If you really do have
witchcraft at your disposal,
then why don't you just abracadabra
that goddamn bitch out
of my afterlife, huh?
I'm sorry for your loss (chaws)
You want a bite?
This is shite!
Pure shite!
Where are the writers, huh?
The writers!
Are you hiding? I shouldn't blame you.
I couldn't toast a piece of bread
with the heat they were putting on you.
I just wanted to bring these
by as a little peace offering
for Addy disturbing your slumber.
- Thank you.
- I think I'm gonna have to
start strapping her in at night--
For a man whose profession
relies on talk, talk, talk,
you appear to be at a
loss for words, Doctor.
What's the matter? Cat got your tongue?
Now there's one thing you
learn before leaving this place
it's that we, even the weakest
among us,
are better than the best of them.
I have grieved enough for two lifetimes.
Most people would be broken by
the deaths of their children,
but my nature would not
permit such weakness.
I am not the same as everyone.
You brought death into this place
and for that,
you must pay.
I also remember every time
I see that ghostly eye,
that I was and continue to be
a hell of a shot.
So that was twenty lashes each,
so that makes forty for you,
Sir Galahad.
(eerie music)
Once I discovered that he had cheated,
Hugo meant no more to me than dog shit.
You know, I've never
understood you Bible-thumpers
and your hypocrisy towards sex.
I know, behind closed doors,
you are the biggest perverts of all.
I would kill or die for you,
but I will not
share the affections of the
men I bring into this house
with any woman, you understand?
I've lived a disreputable life.
But I've done it in style,
and I'll die likewise.
I wouldn't shed a tear if you were to die.
Not because you're a freak,
but because you betrayed me.
You were sloppy, little witch bitch.
- Go to hell, you stupid hag.
(eerie music)
(whoosh)
(bang)
- Oh, they're not for you.
At your age?
You may as well just
crazy-glue a stick of butter to your ass.
- Are you in charge here?
- I'm Fiona Goode (chuckles).
(whispers) I'm in charge everywhere.
- I love you.
- Ewh.
- Why do you look so jet-lagged?
- I happen to look wonderful.
- And when they dig up that
backyard and find my bones,
you'll go to prison.
- There's not going to be a
swimming pool, you stupid slut.
Ah yes, you know I've read
your columns about baked beans,
gallivanting geese who
lost their way home.
Riveting.
Too bad your ambition
outweighs your talent.
You can go as Snoopy again.
The costume will still fit
if you lay off those chocolate chips.
- [Stanley] Please, please, please.
- You tried to kill my dreams,
but they cannot be murdered.
- He's dead and I'm here, and I'm alive
and I still love you!
- That's your problem.
- Have you any idea with
whom you are speaking?
- Yes.
The maid, unless you
wanna go back in the box.
Dr. Thredson,
you are but a guest in our institution.
Don't wear out your welcome the first day.
They are a part of me,
just like that unborn
child is a part of me
and I will not have you
put your filthy hands
on my grandchild.
- He's a deity, show some respect.
(whoosh)
(chokes)
- Respect is something
that is definitely lacking around here,
I will grant you that.
Sorry about all this.
You touch my kid one more time
and I will break your goddamn arm.
(door slams)
(sirens wail)
So, Detective,
what false accusation have
you prepared for us now?
(loud bangs)
Idiots.
(whoosh)
(bangs)
Now, likely I won't have the upper body
strength to saw you in half
the way you did my poor Travis,
but I certainly
could cut off
the smaller parts!
- No, no, no, no, no
- In about ten seconds,
I'm gonna turn the heat up in
that chubby melon of yours,
and I'm gonna turn your
brains to scrambled eggs.
(gulps)
But Frankly,
it's been a hard morning,
and I'd really rather not work up a sweat.
(nervous gulps)
I bet the kiddies scatter
like little buggies
when you walk down the street.
(splash)
It's all my business, you prick.
(spits)
Who are you to talk to me like that?
I'd move if I were you,
(low eerie music)
Don't make me kill you again.
Who do you think you are,
coming in here,
swanning around, spewing vulgarities?
- We're the new owners, who are you?
- I'm Constance Langdon.
And this...
is my fucking house.